>>> PROGRESS IN THE PANDEMIC.
AVERAGE NEW CASES ARE AT THEIR
LOWEST POINT SINCE AUGUST.
70,000 PEOPLE ARE HOSPITALIZED
RIGHT NOW, DOWN FROM 100,000 A
MONTH AGO.
AVERAGE DAILY DEATHS BELOW
2,000.
CNN'S ELIZABETH COHEN ARE
JOINING US NOW.
LOOK, THESE ARE REAL NUMBERS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE AFFECTED.
THIS IS DEFINITELY TRENDING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
>> IT IS TRENDING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
REMEMBER WE WERE TALKING BACK
AND JUNE, IS THIS THE BEGINNING
OF THE END.
I THINK IT DOES GIVE SOME HOPE
THAT THINGS MIGHT BE APPROXIMATE
GOING BETTER THAN THEY WERE
BEFORE.
LET'S LOOK AT HOSPITALIZATIONS.
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT DEATHS,
IT'S NOT AS DRAMATIC.
THE DECLEAN HAS BEEN VERY, VERY
SMALL.
THE DEATHS FOLLOW
HOSPITALIZATIONS.
SO HOPEFULLY WHEN WE'RE TALKING
SEVERAL WEEKS FROM NOW, WE WILL
HAVE A DEATH GRAPHIC THAT LOOKS
LIKE THAT HOSPITALIZATIONS
GRAPHIC.
I MEAN, WE'RE STILL DEALING WITH
ABOUT 2,000 PEOPLE DEALING IN
THE UNITED STATES EVERY DAY.
WHAT WOULD GET THIS RECOVERY TO
GO FASTER, MORE PEOPLE GETTING
VACCINATED.
IF WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE MOST
RECENT VACCINATION NUMBERS,
NEARLY 76% OF AMERICANS HAVE HAD
AT LEAST ONE SHOT OF A COVID-19
VACCINE AND ABOUT 64% ARE FULLY
VACCINATED.
>> I DO WANT TO ASK YOU THIS
TALK.
THERE WAS TALK THAT ONCE THE
FDA-APPROVED VACCINES THERE
WOULD BE A SPIKE IN
VACCINATIONS.
DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> KIND OF, SORT OF.
IT DID NOT HAPPEN AS
DRAMATICALLY AS ANYONE WOULD
LIKE.
WE WERE WONDERING WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THAT.
PFIZER GOT FULL APPROVAL AUGUST
23rd.
WE ASKED THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES FOR
THEIR NUMBERS.
THEY SAID, LOOK, WHEN YOU
COMPARE WHAT HAPPENED TO PFIZER
IN THE DAYS FOLLOWING AUGUST
23rd, TO MODERNA YOU DO SEE A
DIFFERENCE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
IN THE DAYS FOLLOWING THE 23rd
AND THE 12 DAYS AFTER, YOU DO
SEE THE SEVEN-DAY AVERAGE OF
VACCINATIONS GOING UP 16%.
THAT IS A NICE SPIKE.
MODERNA WENT UP 5%.
IT HAD BEEN DOING BETTER IN THE
VACCINATION RATE INCREASES.
SO THERE WAS A SWITCH, AND
PFIZER STARTED DOING BETTER.
DO WE KNOW THAT'S BECAUSE OF
FULL APPROVAL 100%?
NO.
BUT THAT IS PROBABLY A MAJOR
REASON.
BOTH WERE WREUFLY SHORT-LIVED.
AND THEN THE RATES STARTED TO GO
DOWN AROUND SEPTEMBER 4th.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
KAISER FAMILY FOUNDATION POLLS
SAY.
IT SEEMS TO MATTER MORE THAN
FULL APPROVAL.
IF YOU KNOW SOMEONE WHO WAS ILL
OR DIED FROM COVID, THAT WAS
MORE LIKELY TO BE LIKE A MAJOR
REASON FOR GETTING A COVID-19
VACCINE.
THEY WERE PARTICIPATING IN
CERTAIN ACTIVITIES.
IT WAS A STRONGER REASON FOR
PEOPLE WANTING TO GET
VACCINATED.
OR SEEING HOSPITALS FILLING UP
WITH COVID CASES.
I'M GOING TO QUOTE YOU BACK TO
YOU.
YOU SAID FEAR AND FEAR OF
MISSING OUT.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES PEOPLE GET
VACCINATED.
AND I THINK YOU NAILED IT.
.
>> FEAR AND FOMO.
THAT'S WHAT FOMO IS, FOR THE
FOLKS WHO DON'T KNOW.
>> FEAR AND FOMO.
>> ELIZABETH COHEN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
JOHN.
>> THANKS.
>>> WE ARE NOW NEAR THE END OF
IT.
700,000 PEOPLE HAVE NOW DIED IN
THE UNITED STATES.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF OTHERS
BATTLING CORONAVIRUS IN THE
HOSPITAL.
SO WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED AND HOW
CAN WE MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN AGAIN?
I'M JOINED BY ONE MAN WHO HELPED
GUIDE US THROUGH THIS UNCERTAIN
TIME, CNN CHIEF MEDICAL
CORRESPONDENT, DR. SANJAY GUPTA.
NEW BOOK, "WORLD WAR C."
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU HAD TIME TO
WRITE IT.
>> WE TALK ABOUT STUFF ON TV BUT
YOU DO HOURS AND HOURS OF
HOMEWORK TO DO A FEW MINUTES ON
TELEVISION.
IT'S BEEN MY LIFE REALLY FOR TWO
YEARS.
I'VE BEEN SO IMMERSED.
THERE ARE SEVERAL THINGS.
THE SCIENCE OF THE VIRUS.
REALLY WHAT DOES THIS VIRUS DO
FOR THE BODY.
HOW DOES IT CAUSE ISOLATED LOSS
OF SMELL.
IT IS FASCINATING AND IMPORTANT,
I THINK.
WE'RE IN A WHOLE NEW ERA OF THE
VIRUS.
THE VACCINE, HOW DOES THAT, TWO.
JUST THE SCIENCE LESSONS.
I WANTED TO TEACH THAT.
HUMAN BEHAVIOR.
THERE'S BEEN SO MANY SURPRISES.
HOW WE EVALUATE RISK.
TELL SOMEBODY IS.5% LETHAL.
THAT WAS INTERESTING SAYING
LET'S DO EVERYTHING TO BE
PROTECTED.
OTHER PEOPLE SAY I'M 99% GOOD.
SAME OBJECTIVE DATA, DIFFERENT
SUBJECTIVE INTERPRETATIONS OR
THE THINGS THAT ARE NOVEL.
KIDS DEAL WITH NOVEL THINGS ALL
THE TIME.
ADULTS DON'T.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME YOU
EXPERIENCED SOMETHING FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
ALSO, HOW DO YOU GET OUT OF YOUR
OWN WAY AND SAY LET ME TAKE THIS
FOR WHAT IT IS.
A LOT OF LESSONS THERE.
.
>> YEAH.
HOW DO YOU GET OUT OF YOUR OWN
WAY.
THE UNITED STATES DIDN'T.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
I REMEMBER SO EARLY ON,
FEBRUARY, MARCH, APRIL OF 2020,
THE UNITED STATES WAS DOING
WORSE THAN OTHER COUNTRIES.
>>> YEAH.
I THINK THERE IS ALWAYS THIS
IDEA THAT WEALTH WILL BUY
HEALTH.
WE'RE THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE ALL OF THESE RESOURCES
TO THROW AT SOMETHING.
WEALTHY COUNTRIES DID WORSE.
MALARIA, TUBERCULOSIS, THEY
AFFECTED THIRD WORLD COUNTRIES
THAN DEVELOPED COUNTRIES.
NOT SO WITH THIS DISEASE.
WHY?
WAS IT BECAUSE WE WAITED FOR THE
HOME RUN HIT IN THE FORM OF A
VACCINE AND COULDN'T BE BOTHERED
TO USE MASKS AND OTHER BASIC
PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURES?
PERHAPS.
WE THINK OF THE IDEA THAT WE
HAVE THESE DISEASES OF
PRIVILEGE.
OBESITY, HEART DISEASE, THINGS
THAT MADE US MORE VULNERABLE TO
THE DISEASE.
COULD THAT HAVE BEEN A PROBLEM?
THEY SET US UP FOR WORSE
OUTCOMES.
ALL OF THESE THINGS THAT YOU
THINK ABOUT MADE IT MORE LIKELY
THAT WEALTHY COUNTRIES WERE
GOING TO DO POORER.
IF YOU LOOK AT ALL THESE
PANDEMICS, JOHN, THE COUNTRY OF
OR GENERAL OF THE PANDEMIC IS
OFTEN THE COUNTRY THAT WAS THE
LEAST HARD HIT.
.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH.
.
>> SO 1918, THE PANDEMIC
PROBABLY STARTED HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IT WAS COUNTRIES FURTHER AND
FURTHER AWAY FROM THE UNITED
STATES THAT WAS HARDER HIT.
CHINA, WITH THIS PANDEMIC, NOT
AS HARD HIT.
WHY IS THAT?
COULD THERE BE A LOW LEVEL
CIRCULATING IMMUNITY WITH
PREVARIANTS?
IT SETS UP AN INTERESTING
QUESTION HOW WE SURVEIL GOING
FORWARD.
RIGHT NOW WE JUST GET HIT, ALL
OF A SUDDEN WE'RE DEALING WITH
IT.
BUT THERE ARE THE PRESHOCKS AS
WELL.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT OF THAT.
THAT IS SOMETHING.
GETTING HEALTHIER IN GERM,
SANJAY, YOU SAY IS HUGELY
IMPORTANT.
.
>> DR. ROBERT REDFIELD, WHO WAS
THE CDC DIRECTOR, SAID WE DID
NOT SHOW UP TO THIS BATTLE WITH
VERY GOOD ARMOR ON.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS AN
INTERESTING PHRASE.
THAT WAS ABOUT A YEAR AGO WE HAD
THIS CONVERSATION.
AND I STARTED DIGGING.
IT IS TRUE WE HEARD THE NUMBER
OF CO MORBIDITIES, THE HIGHER
THE LIKELIHOOD OF A WORSE
OUTCOME.
OB
OBESITY, CHRONIC KIDNEY DISEASE
REALLY SET YOU UP FOR
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS DOWN THE
ROAD.
WE KNOW WE NEED TO GET
HEALTHIER.
BUT THAT YOU COULD SO DIRECTLY
TIE THESE DECEASES TO A WORSE
OUTCOME MADE THE ISSUE THAT MUCH
MORE URGENT.
AND ALSO, YOU KNOW, JUST EVEN
YOUR IMMUNITY.
PEOPLE SAY I WANT TO DO THINGS
TO BUILD UP MY IMMUNITY.
HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
GET HEALTHY, OF COURSE.
BUT SO MUCH IMMUNITY COMES FROM
YOUR GUT, MICROBIOME.
THIS ONE MICROBIOME RESEARCHER
SAID TO ME WHAT YOU HAVE FOR
BREAKFAST TODAY COULD GIVE YOU A
GOOD IDEA OF TONIGHT, HOW MUCH
IT INFLUENCES YOUR IMMUNITY AND
HOW LIKELY YOU ARE TO COMBAT A
DISEASE LIKE COVID.
>> CHEERIOS AND FOUR ESPRESSOS.
HOW AM I DOING?
.
>> YOU'RE DOING FINE.
IT IS WHAT OUR PERSONAL
OBLIGATIONS ARE FOR EMERGING
PATHOGENS GOING FORWARD.
THEY WILL KEEP HAPPENING.
PANDEMICS DON'T HAVE TO.
.
>> THE BOOK IS "WORLD WAR C."
SANJAY, WE'RE SO PROUD, WE'RE